welcome to Hannity all right just
breaking as we speak tonight well we
call him creepy and crazy uncle Joe
Biden for a reason well now he's facing
a second accusation of inappropriate
touching been a rough week for the
Democratic Party and it's only Monday
congresswoman Acacio cortes embarrassing
herself yet again senator Elizabeth
Warren running out of other people's
money and want to be colonists and
communists Oh Bernie Sanders he can't
answer a simple question about his own
policies and you just heard the breaking
news creepy crazy uncle Joe Biden he's
facing a serious backlash for you
guessed it being creepy
we begin tonight with our Hannity watch
on the radical 20/20 extreme Democratic
Socialist well he hasn't yet formally
entered the race but already well creepy
Uncle Joe is facing two separate
allegations now of inappropriate
touching and a lot more just a short
time ago a Connecticut woman named Amy
la pose told The Hartford Courant quote
he put his hand around my neck he pulled
me in to rub noses with me when he was
pulling me in I thought he was going to
kiss me on the mouth meanwhile the first
accusation came from former Democratic
lawmaker Lucy Flores a Nevada who
encountered the vice president backstage
at a political event in 2014 she
claiming crazy Uncle Joe got close to
her from behind was sniffing and
smelling her hair and planted an
unsolicited kiss on the back of her head
saying quote my brain couldn't process
what was happening I was embarrassed I
was shocked I was confused
let's take a look Eva Longoria was there
we were all lined up next to the stage
Eva was in front of me Joe Biden was
behind me I'm kind of preparing myself
to give these remarks it's the very last
days before the election and very
unexpectedly and out of nowhere
I feel Joe Biden put his hands on my
shoulders get up very close to me from
behind
lean in smell my hair and then plant a
slow kiss on the top of my head alright
smelling someone's hair
from behind rubbing noses kissing a
stranger some on the lips who does that
apparently Joe Biden and he does a lot
now creepy Uncle Joe is a nickname that
he's earned through the years look at
your screen cringe-inducing very awkward
touching grabbing kissing here stroking
and smelling and nose rubbing and the
woman you just heard from told political
quote it's so easy to google creepy
Biden everyone is entitled to due
process in the presumption of innocence
but problem here for Joe Biden is there
are dozens and dozens of pictures and
videos showing these kind of encounters
Biden offered a half-hearted apology
saying doesn't believe he ever acted
inappropriately and that brings us to a
very important question
well the Democratic Party hold Biden to
the same believe all women I believe
zero tolerance standard that they have
utilized so vigorously against
Republicans by the way where are all the
Cavanaugh I believers know so far the
radical socialist 2020 Democrats who
don't want Biden to win they're coming
out against the former VP but obviously
that's for political expediency and
creepy Uncle Joe superfans in the
mainstream media they're singing a much
different tune they love him take a look
to make a big kerfuffle out of this with
a man who's done nothing but spend his
life in the service of others I think is
just wrong what else he supposed to do
you know Lucy I'm sorry I you know got
too close to you I mean seriously what
else is he supposed to do it's one
person of allegation that's five years
old and that cannot negate or change or
diminish in any way Joe Biden's very
strong record empowering women
he is extremely affectionate extremely
flirtatious in a completely safe way but
are we allowed to bring up that Lucy
Flores is a huge Bernie person and she
has you know political connections that
might be countered what am i fighting
schools and up this could be we're hold
on is it okay to bring up this could be
politically motivated
no surprise sucking up to creepy crazy
Uncle Joe that's the same medium mob who
tried to ruin judge Cavanaugh's life
over wild thirty-year-old uncorroborated
allegations and some cryptic high school
yearbook posts don't expect the media to
ever properly vet Joe Biden they didn't
do it in 2008 to the chosen one the one
that gave them thrills up their leg
Barack Obama they're not going to do it
to any of the 20/20 candidates on the
extreme Democratic Socialist side so it
will be up to us here on this program
because there are so many red flags
about Joe Biden other than this constant
need to touch and Stroke and kiss and
rub noses look I'll let you be the judge
of the pictures you see I'm personally
not a fan of people to get right in your
grill we've all met people like that
right it's so close to your face your
nose is almost do touch even if you take
a step back they move in more and people
the kind of massage other people go up
and rub in their shoulders and want to
kiss others on the lips you don't even
know them a lot of this creeps me out
but you'll decide tonight we start with
Biden's those sketchy passed on race in
America this will be an issue for him
for a Democratic Party so obsessed with
identity politics this is not a good
look for a presidential candidate
take a look you cannot go to a 7-eleven
or a Dunkin Donuts unless you have a
slight Indian accent
not much of what kind of a chance with a
northeastern liberal like Joe Biden
stand in the South better than anybody
else and you don't know my state my
state was a slave state my state is a
border state my state is the eighth
largest black population in the country
we've got the first right
Romney wants to let that he said the
first hundred days he's gonna let the
big banks once again write their own
rules unchain Wall Street
you're gonna put y'all back in Chains
first mainstream african-american
articulate clean you know that story
book Wow
all right that's right so the person
currently polling highest in the
Democratic primary is a man who called
the president clean articulate and story
book man he bragged that his home state
was a slave state you can't work at a
7-eleven or a Dunkin Donuts unless you
have a slight Indian accent that's your
Democratic frontrunner and no surprise
considering in 1975 most of the meeting
will never bring this up a younger
senator Biden fought hard against the
practice used to desegregate schools
known as busing in other words he didn't
want integration take a look I think the
concept of busing which implicit in that
concept is the question you just asked
or the the statement within the question
you just asked that we are going to
integrate people so that they all have
the same access and they learn to grow
up with one another and and and all the
rest is a rejection of the whole
movement of black pride now that very
same Biden told the local newspaper
quote I don't feel responsible for the
sins of my father grandfather I'll be
damned if I feel responsible to pay for
what happened three hundred years ago
two decades later as chair of the Senate
Judiciary Committee senator Biden
presided over Justice Clarence Thomas's
confirmation which we know turned into a
circus just as Thomas calling it a
modern day lynching Biden offered an
apology
well just last week he went on an
apology tour because he's offered it to
Anita Hill the accuser of Justice Thomas
he's been on this tour now apologizing
for over a week take a look Anita Hill
professor showed the courage of a
lifetime talking about her experience
being harassed by Clarence Thomas we
knew a lot less about the extent of
harassment back then over 30 years ago
but she paid a terrible price she was
abused through the hearing she's taking
advantage of her reputation was attacked
I wish I could have done something
there was a real and perceived problem
the committee faced there are a bunch of
white guys no I mean he's sincerely a
bunch of white guys Webber Adina Hill
didn't follow Clarence Thomas to another
job after the so-called incidents
happened but I guess facts don't want to
be discussed at this time he hasn't even
portal II jumped into the race Biden is
on his first apology tour don't be
fooled
Amtrak Jo tries to paint himself as a
sympathetic champion of the people
look behind the scenes we have
discovered and we will reveal in great
great detail in the days and weeks ahead
shady swampy behavior back in 2014 while
Joe Biden was the vice president his son
Hunter accepted a board seat on
Ukraine's one of the largest oil and gas
companies owned by ukrainian oligarch
facing international money laundering
allegations naturally this very serious
ethical questions and even some scorn
from the left
according to author Peter Schweitzer and
his brand-new book secret empires while
hunter Biden was working at this
Ukrainian oil companies a series of very
suspicious foreign financial
transactions flowed to an account used
by hunter Biden including a
multi-million dollar deposit from that
company now keep in mind this all
occurred while his father was vice
president and get this serving as one of
the key point persons for the Obama
administration's anti-corruption message
in Ukraine well any of this sound
familiar eerily similar to what we
learned about the Clinton Foundation
there was a lot to unpack here and we
will have full coverage of this story in
the days and weeks ahead same story with
China by the way just one more example
of hypocrisy from the left left you got
Clinton Biden everybody in between
Democrats seem to get a free pass on
everything you
our allegations claims of racism sexual
harassment all conservatives Republicans
I believe demonize guilt by accusation
with or without evidence oh and by the
way yeah his son was doing these deals
in China and Ukraine oh he will get to
China tomorrow guess what he was on Air
Force two with his father got a free
trip to do these deals let's look at the
Commonwealth of Virginia more example of
hypocrisy Democratic governor Attorney
General they both admitted to dressing
up in blackface being extremely racist
in the 80s are they facing any
consequences nope what would happen if
it was a Republican and there's a
lieutenant governor just in Fairfax two
separate women have made serious
allegations sexual assault and violent
rape and yet to this day the I believers
Democrats in Virginia they have done
nothing to hold Fairfax accountable and
deafening silence from the very people
saying I believe in the Cavanaugh case
so the party that constantly tells you
and I was to believe women all women
well they don't seem capable of accusing
one of their own lest they want to beat
him in a primary that's why lieutenant
governor Fairfax his first accuser
Vanessa Tyson was compelled to speak out
earlier today we have the tape he's
pushing down and pushing down and I
couldn't hold my neck up and I didn't
know what was going on I honestly didn't
know what was going on and then the next
thing I know like my head is like
literally in his crotch the sexual
assault is an epidemic that's taking
place around the world across our
country every day what do you want to
happen to just in Fairfax why are you
coming forward I'd want him to resign
all right in the coming months and even
tomorrow we're gonna get to see whether
the party of identity politics is
willing to hold themselves to the same
standards they place on everybody else
we're not going to hold our breath but
that is your radical crop of extreme
20/20 Democratic socialists that want to
be President and how they
shamelessly deploy the same old tired
fear tactics and identity politics
always against President Trump take for
example Robert Francis
fado bozo O'Rourke officially kicked off
his campaign this weekend in El Paso
frequently implying that walls are
amoral we should just open up the border
tear down the existing walls there and
Robert Francis well he lives in a
fantasy world because there is a serious
crisis tonight at our southern border
yet again illegal immigration is
experiencing one more time a massive
surge another huge caravan on the way
President Trump has cut aid over the
weekend to three Central American
countries where the caravans are
originating and he's threatening to
close our southern border in Mexico if
Mexico does not do their job and stop
the caravan from marching north we'll
have a lot more coming up in the program
today but first let's turn to another
radical 20/20 candidate who just
predicted millions of people are going
to die sounds like a death panel if
President Trump gets his way to fix keep
your doctor keep your plan Payless
millions lost their doctors lost their
plans and everybody paid more take a
look Trump has an idea on health care
his idea is to throw 32 million
Americans off of the health insurance
they have doing away with insurance for
kids who are 26 years of age or younger
who were on their parents plans doing
away with the protections that the ACA
has for pre-existing conditions Margaret
that means if you have cancer you have
heart disease you have diabetes if Trump
gets his way the cost of health
insurance for you will be so high that
many people literally will not be able
to afford it thousands of people will
literally die actually it's socialism
that has killed millions upon millions
of people and led to more poverty more
suffering every promise every socialist
country makes it's broken
it's unrealistic it is unsustainable
but the greatest standard of living the
greatest country God gave man
the United States of America based on
freedom and opportunity by the way
that's why so many people want to enter
this country illegally they want what we
have every day and we often take for
granted Bernie Sanders socialist
colleague congresswoman Acacio Cortes
they don't seem to have the best grasp
on history for example take a look at
this historical analysis problem
congresswoman Acacio Cortez from over
the weekend this is kind of priceless
when our party was boldest the time of
the new New Deal the Great Society the
Civil Rights Act and so on we had and
carried super majorities in the house in
the Senate we carried the presidency
they had to amend the Constitution of
the United States to make sure Roosevelt
did not get reelected it's a little
problem FDR died in 1945 two years
before presidential term limits were
implemented you would think a person
remember she was going to be sworn into
office you know but somebody's sworn to
uphold and protect the US Constitution
would understand the context of the
amendments to our US Constitution maybe
that's a little too much to expect given
that the congresswoman compared climate
change to world war two 9/11 to
Hurricane Katrina